watching a fruit fly may not be as
captivating as catching Tom Cruise's in
Top Gun but it turns out Cruz has
nothing on the insect when it comes to
doing complicated fighter jet maneuvers
like bank turns scientists didn't even
know that gypsophila high di flies could
turn quickly by rolling in midair until
a team put the insects in a miniature
stadium with a Jumbotron
the screen created the illusion of
something scary coming toward the flies
researchers use three infrared cameras
to see how the flies dodged to the
danger filming an infrared at 7,500
frames a second the team found that the
fly's bank and turned quickly much
faster than the way insects make small
routine turns where there's no danger
this sequence shows the Flies quick turn
at 1/3 hundredths of its natural speed
the fly is veering away from the scary
shape approaching from the bottom right
from the footage the team also created a
computer simulation of the same escape
turn slow to 1 300 the speed and
magnified twice the insect size the
rolling motions became much clearer the
fly rolls its whole body to one side
like a plane raising one of its wings as
it banks the fly then rolls back and
flies off the team reports the results
April 11th in science what's surprising
is that the fly doesn't have a lot of
fancy muscles or brainpower to maneuver
yet it doesn't seamlessly add a small
scale that miniaturization is something
scientists are still trying to
understand